Báo chỉ Việt Nam là nên bao chi cách mà, người đặt nên mống trên nên bao chi cách mà Việt Nam chính là chủ tỷ khu chi Minh.
Người đã tưởng chỉ gió. Báo chỉ của ta thì cần phải phục vụ nhân dần lòng động.
Phục vụ chủ nghĩa xa hội, phục vụ cho đấu trang, thực hiện thống lất tức nhà cho hoa mình kế giới.
Bây giờ vụ của người làm báo là quan trọng, bệnh bán.
Làm ta là quan trịt và bệnh dụ sáng tạo tức tự khu chi Minh về bao chi cách mà.
Cỏi bao chi là bụ khi tư tượng sắc bệnh của đàn.
Cơm phục sự ki vọc của người. Nhiêm tiến của đàn của nhân dần.
Chồng sức một trong năm gia đời và phát triển.
Báo chỉ khi mạng Việt Nam đã quan thành tốt, nhiều buộc về văn phủ mình.
Ý trọng đường dân năng, giải phóng rất tọt, thống nhất rất nước, đến trọng đường xây dự và phát triển rất nước thời kỷ mới.
Này 25 tháng 6 năm 2019, đồng chiến với ai quốc của Chinh Minh đã xuất bản báo thình nhân.
Đây là hành động qua trọng trong hành trị bố 3 tìm được vướng nước của người.
Nhất là trình bị cho việc thành lập chính đàn để lãnh đạo cách mà.
Gửi cho giảm, bố đàn cách mà, chứ hết phải chuyên báo tư tượng cách mà, tư tượng của chúng cái mác lên đi.
Phải văn đông, tổ chức, tập hợp lực lượng cách mà, báo chỉ cách mà, là công cụ cụ kỳ quán trọng để làm nhập cụ đó.
Lịch sử đã trứng mình.
Vìa kêu, lãnh giá đúng vai trò của báo chi, đối với sự nhập cách mà của rất tọt, đã mang lại những tết quả hết sự bẻ bán.
Thao lời của tổn bị thư vệnh của trọng, thì trong các cuộc kháng chiến anh dữ chống xâm lượng bảo vệ tổ quốc.
Báo chi nước ta đã trở thành một binh trục quan trọng trên mặt trận đưa được.
Nếu tác phẩm báo chi đã thực sự là lời hệ kích mà, bếng gọi nó sâu, thuộc sục đông báo cả nước cùng ra trở.
Ở trong mẫu lở chính trành, hàng chăm nhà báo, chính sĩ của chúng ta đã anh dụng hị sinh.
Gó phần tố tham thêm, chang sự vệ văn của báo chi kích mà của rất tọt Việt Nam anh vùng.
Báo phẩm thêm, báo chi tiếp tục sức mạnh khách mà của mình, với những nghiệm buộc mới không cạnh phẩm quan trọng.
Những người làm báo, tiếp tục là đối quan trủ lực trong việc liệt lứng dưới lợt sà hội, tuyên chuyên của vụ, đông viên toàn đàn, toàn dân, toàn quân, thực hiện thắng lợi dưới lỗi đổi mới, soàn đàn ra khởi sướng và lãnh đạo.
Cái trình đang giám xác phản bây giờ của báo chi kỳ này theo dôn nó phải được nổi đêm.
Nếu được phản thật, giám xác là giám xác của anh tình thực thi, chỉ trách thực thi của sản.
Giám xác của anh tình thực thi của hộ của gặn đường không trước, đá hợp và pháp hợp.
Rồi phản bình chỉ trách.
Được nhắc tới và nhìn được sự quan tâm của nhiều đầm viên, các tần lực nhân dân thời gian qua,
là công cuộc phòng chống tham nữ lãnh phi têu cờ.
Đây được viên như một mặt chật, vì không có tiếng xuống, nhưng đặc biệt quan trọng,
bởi nó mấy cơ đen gióa sự tôn văn của đàn và chỉ đồ.
Trong cuộc chiến chúng giả lượt sâm này, báo chi lãnh một lần lửa, rà sức, là vụ khi sắc mẹ của đàn.
Báo chi giúp phát hiện nhiều vụ an vụ việc tham nữ lãnh phi têu cờ, từ việc phương, từ chục ương,
lời vật có vụ an trị sôn thành,
của an đất vàng sắp vụ cô,
tương nhiên vụ việc bầu nghiệm cả một thần tóc là em ngoài,
cả nhà lăng quan trị hà dàng,
đến vụ việc cả một phát ninh bỏ nghiệm sở, thì đến gốc,
thấy giáo mất trế độ an của học sinh để lảo dài.
Rồi nãy nhát, là những vụ an trên quan đến thang dạ, thằng kém chất hợp.
Báo chi đã và đang tấn công vật tương vọng mắt trên chật chuyến càng gòn.
Rồi vụ việc mất đưa đêm bán, thì các cơ quan trị ngang rọng của
những điều chà, lương nhiên, cứ, tìm nắm được tương vọng.
Trời này lần nhiều, báo chi mạng tính rắn rắn.
Họ phát hiện rắn rắn, khi chúng ta đọng vô trên bán, chúng ta thấy một hình dựa.
Chí quên mất, cái này, ở chúng tôi không biết,
chúng tôi chưa biết, lại vì báo chi nói, lại chúng tôi nắm lại.
Đúng không?
Bây giờ ở dạng là họ phải tương nhận,
để chuyện lần báo chi khó vệ vài chọn rất phần trạng, vì tiền phòng đánh với chuyện.
Báo chi chuyện này có tắt động lớn về sự phát triển của mọng mặt đất nước,
ở chính trị, cái kinh tế xác hội.
Cũng bị vậy, mạng ở nhiều yếu tố có tắt động nộng lại với báo chi.
Báo chi cũng đang phải đối mặt với nhiều phét thức.
Ngày Ngày, bên cạnh đổi mũ nhạm báo trình trình,
cũng có những người, mũ nhên dành, nhà bảo,
đứng ngoài không cuộc sây dự và bảo vệ tố quốc,
lợi giụng phản biển xác hội,
để nói lên tiếng nói là ngọt,
xa dời tôn chỉ một lịch của báo chi,
thì eu chết nghiệp xác hội và nặn nước người nghiệp.
Đó là điều không thể chật dạng.
Báo chi tiếp tục xứ mạnh cách mạng,
thực sự là vụ khi sắp bến của đàn trên mạng trận tư tưởng,
báo chi cần được trạo điều kiện hoạt động theo đối vải chất chức năng của mình.
Đồng thời cũng tắt lãnh đạo của báo chi
cũng cần được lột mới và quan tâm hình đường.
Nói tên nào để quyết hoạt được,
trong báo chi giám trác phản biển xác.
Thậm chí là có chế tạng.
Để giá hoạt cho báo chi,
tất nhiệp giám trác phản biển xác hội,
các chiến thách và các quyết xác để báo đàn lăng.
Cả, quyết xác và chiến thách của đàn nhận nước,
điều không cuộc sống.
Báo kịch năng, báo kịch tục tế,
báo bình năng, trong kỳ tời buổi này,
tự nhiên cần phải quan tâm thư trụ sống.
Thăng tích trụ sống.
Không chảy thông hạn xác hội.
Chơi đó rồi hỏi nhà báo và tình nào,
có kinh thức,
phải có tâm đi.
Kinh thức,
cảm giác, cảm giác,
thì tâm mình cảm giác.
Báo chi cân trụ đọc thông tinh trụ đọc phản biển.
Thứ,
xong,
tưa nó,
nó phải xíu sống của nền tuyên thông của chả.
Nạn của uống phải tiếp tục lập.
Sát xác lành đạo của anh đi màu chi,
về nội giống thư trở.
Và báo nền,
được những ý kiến hông viết.
Hông viết chế tiếp tục.
Mời khi mà họ phản này nhé.
Mà muốn là như thế thì phải tụi chức nhiều của các cửa.
Hông phải gặp hữa lại đạo báo chi.
Mà gặp hữa các cửa khóng vuyền của thế.
Nếu ruyên đi đàn,
mình nắm được,
kết cơ quan,
kết thức sự.
Là,
trong đồng hông viên thì hình hình bị dễ.
Bản thân các nhà báo,
cũng như vậy là họ mang tình và thịt,
nhưng mà họ cũng có quyền.
Nên nâng bị tính phản biển đến họ cũng có quyền,
hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình hình.
Nên thông như thế nào.
Để mà cho nó hiểu qua.
Báo chi vụ của anh.
Cô hỏi,
nhưng chính là sự nhấn mạnh của chủ triệu của chị Minh,
lối với những buộc cao cả của báo chi kết màn Việt Nam.
Báo chi của ta,
phải phục vụ,
nhưng rất là đậu.
Phục vụ cho đấu tranh giải phóng sinh tọng thống nhất đất ngạch,
xây sự trụ những xa hội trong quả bịn thế giới.
Và để thực hiện được trọng vện nghiệp vụ đó.
Đàn phải lấy đạo báo chi,
một miếng tắc mắt gì bắt gì.
Điều này tạo nên tính tàn của báo chi kết màn Việt Nam.
Đây là điều căn cót nhất trong tư tượng của Chím Minh,
về báo chi kết màn Việt Nam,
là cơ sở để phân biệt báo chi kết màn,
với báo chi phạt kết màn.
Báo chi, chỉ đúng về chiến trị.
khi nó đường lĩnh đạo của bắt đạo.
Rất trên nền tàng chúng như mắt lên in,
một đạn mặt bản chất của xanh cấp công nhân
và rắn bóng mặt thích với xanh tọng với nhân dân.